estos camiones están estacionados en una
autopista del suroeste de Alemania Hace
cuatro semanas la razón protesta de
transportistas precarizados en su
mayoría huecos y georgianos contra las
empresas polacas look más acmas e
imperias pertenecientes al empresario
lucasmasur cansados de las malas
condiciones laborales Los camioneros se
apoderaron de los vehículos y permanecen
en suelo alemán por temor a regresar a
Polonia
nos descontaron 400 euros de nuestro
salario y no nos avisaron eso inició
nuestra huelga y después de eso exigimos
la cantidad de dinero que siempre
retuvieron del salario en un solo
Mesías
también me gustaría agregar que nos
amenazan si vamos a Polonia prometen que
nos detendrán y queremos una garantía de
que nadie nos tocará si entramos
la situación se tensó en los últimos
días luego de que la empresa polaca
enviara a un grupo de pandilleros de la
milicia privada patru con un vehículo
blindado y 18 hombres armados agredieron
físicamente a los trabajadores este
accionar de la compañía despertó la
indignación de los sindicatos alemanes y
de distintos países europeos Quienes se
unieron a la protesta en Solidaridad
la empresa vino con gangsters polacos
para intentar golpear a los conductores
y recuperar sus camiones el empleador y
esos gangsters terminaron siendo
arrestados Hace tres semanas comenzamos
aquí con el empleador diciendo a esos
tipos no les debo dinero ahora están
empezando a pagar de a poco
si bien hay algunos avances en las
negociaciones la empresa de transporte
polaca presentó cargos contra los
trabajadores por apropiación indebida de
los camiones un conflicto que parece que
no se resolverá pronto